[Music]
voices against bullying navigating
school bullying welcome to another
episode of voices against bullying I'm
your host Amina ibrahimi and in today's
episode we'll be discussing a critical
issue that affects many young people
across the globe bullying in schools
we'll hear stories insights and expert
advice on how to address the and prevent
bullying in educational settings join us
as we shed light into this important
topic understanding school bullying
bullying is a widespread issue but it's
essential to start by understanding what
it is we'll Define and discuss the
various forms of bullying including
physical verbal and cyber bullying we
will also explore the psychological
impact on
victims personal stories we'll hear from
individuals who have experienced bowling
in school they will share their personal
Stories the emotions they went through
and how they coped with the situation
these real life experiences offer a
unique perspective on the issue the role
of schools schools play a pivotal role
in addressing bullying we'll talk to
Educators counselors and administrators
about their experience dealing with
bullying
incidents they will discuss school
policies prevention programs and the
challenges they face in creating a safe
environment strategies to combat
bullying our experts will provide
practical advice on how to prevent and
address bullying we will explore
strategies for parents teachers and
students to combat bullying effectively
we will also discuss the importance of
fostering empathy and promoting a
culture of respect legal and ethical
aspects bullying often involves complex
legal and ethical aspects we will have a
legal expert on the show to discuss the
legal REM ifications of bullying and the
right of students we will also delve
into the ethical responsibilities of
school and Society building resilence
it's crucial to help victims build
resilence we'll talk to mental health
professionals about techniques for
emotional recovery and self-esteem
building we will also discuss the
importance of peer support and
counseling listener questions we have
received questions from our listeners
and we'll address some of them if you
have any questions or stories to share
please reach out to us for future
episodes bullying schools is a serious
issue that affects the lives of
countless young people it's our
responsibility to take a stand against
it and work towards a safe and inclusive
educational environment for all thank
you for joining us on this episode of
voices against bullying if you found
this podcast informative and helpful
please share it with your friends family
and Community together we can make a
differ difference P.S don't forget to
subscribe to our podcast for more
important discussion and remember you
are not alone there are people who care
and resources are available to help
thanks for tuning in to voices against
bullying we'll be back with another
episode soon
bye